16th anniversary wedding anniversary
yeah good for you it's a long time it's
in May 24 oh man I almost forgot it May
24th is our wedding in yeah yeah and
actually the this is that this makes me
laugh okay so when we might not make you
laugh it makes me laugh but I am well
doesn't matter it's just a paper boat
when we our first date was this show
called stones in his pockets you went
and saw a theatrical theatrical yeah in
New York is called stones in his pockets
by this author named Maria Jones I
believe very good play but I was very
nervous because was my first date with
her and I was kind of not there anyways
so anyways years later not years later a
year later we got engaged and I thought
I'd be kind of neat to get engaged in
the place where this play took place and
it took place in Killarney Ireland and I
was a golf flyer to killarney Ireland
and I'll ask her to marry me and the
stone in my pocket will be the ring oh
that's romantic nice yeah
it all comes full service so anyways
well she said yes yeah you gotta so then
okay then then cut two years later we're
in Baltimore shooting deep and the place
stones in his pockets is playing in
Baltimore and I'm like oh my gosh this
was our first date I'm gonna go see it
Martel wasn't there she was back in LA I
think I'm gonna go see this play and
just enjoy it okay I clearly was not
present in my first date cuz the show
centers around a suicide and the stones
in his pockets is what he used to drown
himself this is your big romantic play
well
oh yeah so I I called Martel after I saw
the play and I was like Martel when I
took you Arland and I centered this you
know our engagement around the place
stones in his pockets did you think that
was kind of odd and she's like yeah but
I don't want to ruin your buzz and then
she goes yeah I kept thinking am i the
stone that's gonna drag you to your
death and suffocate your life it's not I
mean I've met your wife she has a good
sense of humor it'll be very good since
she is she good it sort of keeping you
in check you know oh yeah seems like
that's a big part of the deal well yeah
I mean I don't know if Liza does this
but it's yes my wife not Liza Minnelli
cuz I know you're all thinking what is
Liza Minnelli have to do with this Liza
Minelli's my first wife but you're so
good at this
are you putting things in context good
anyways you really are so anyways like
my wife I'll say something and then
sometimes sure go I'll give a button or
something should be like is that it and
all that kind of stuff or running lines
with her is kind of rough sometimes
cuz she'll just say like are you gonna
do that with your hands or that's how
she'll give you like criticism is yeah
she's lovely she's a which is a
wonderful human being but should be kind
of like is that how you're gonna do it
yeah to me I find that that role as my
wife is very supportive my kids are very
happy to be like literally I'll say
something you like try again
[Laughter]